es gibt auch menschen die see team schon
ziemlich ähnlich und ein begrüße ich
jetzt hier ist aviatik ich grüße sie
herzlich jetzt muss man dazu direkt
sagen herr tichy dass sie sich jetzt
nicht extra verkleidet haben für heute
abend sondern sie sind von beruf oder
nebenberuf können sie dann nochmal
erzählen diego maradona doppelgänger wie
kam es dazu ja das stimmt
ich tue denn diego armando maradona
schon seit über 25 jahre doppeln und
hatte auch das vergnügen ego
kennenzulernen und entdeckt wurde ich
von bild und der bild zeitung wie sollte
es anders sein wie es in denn
aufgefallen hertie dass sie madonna so
ähnlich sehen war es plötzlich so dass
sie in der kino schlange immer
vorgelassen wurden oder dass man ihnen
den ball zuspielte und sagte komm lass
mal krachen
nein nein ich selber wusste es nicht
dass ich so aussehe wie diego erst in
der berufsschule mit 17 18 jahre
meine mitschüler haben das entdeckt und
sie haben und ein poster aufgehängt und
dann ist maradona für mich geboren
ich war ein großer fan von karlheinz
förster in meiner jugend ok das ist ja
eher so die die harte gangart wo es auch
mal richtig zur sache geht
ich glaube förster müsste auch im 86er
finale gespielt haben gegen die
argentinier was kostet ein maradona
doppelgänger auftritt für die bekamen
sie buchen
8 das wird geld spreche hier nicht
dabei im management wie nachgefragt ist
denn ein maradona google eigentlich gab
es da zwischendurch mal so eine stelle
wo man ihn eher mit skandalen in
verbindung gebracht hat oder ist
maradona das ganze jahr über gefragt ja
das stimmt allerdings halte ich für
maradona ist sehr begehrt immer noch
obwohl er seine skandale gehabt hat denn
ich musste es alles wieder gerade gesagt
so schlecht ist dann maradona gar nicht
herr tichy wir danken ganz herzlich für
die zeit und diese ähnlichkeit ist
wirklich passiert auch umgekehrt sie
eine frage haben wir noch keinen und
eine frage stellen ausdrücklich nur für
einen freund herr tichy wie oft hat
ihnen denn das aussehen von maradona
geholfen um bei den damen gut anzukommen
kann ich mir vorstellen er hat also auch
spaß mit oder immer immer sehr sogar
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
weil die schau dich je das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren